do you fear death and then now i do
right in this moment you do or do you
mean generally speaking i do look
uh i am as intellectually
convinced as one can possibly be that
my core subjectivity is in your which is
the same in you which is the same in my
cat and everywhere
uh is the one entity in the reduction
base
in in other words all reality unfolds in
it it's it's the one thing that exists
and therefore it has nowhere to go
and it's never going to end it's where
beginnings and sorry what has no way
not what what is the core subjectivity
in me
is going nowhere because everything that
happens
happens in it and it's not only my
course objectivity the course
objectivity in me is the same course
objectivity in you
it's the one eye of the world that looks
out from every creature as schopenhauer
put it
so i'm as intellectually convinced as
one can be
that my subjectivity survives bodily
death and probably witnesses
the entire process now what is the best
and safe analog to death we have today
what's the
the one thing we can do that comes the
closest to death
physiologically and and still can be
done safely
let's hide those psychedelics the
psychedelics the way they operate is by
significantly reducing brain activity
not in this spirit not sorry not
anesthesia
anesthesia is a dissociative it
increases noise levels in your brain
it doesn't necessarily reduce brain
activity and
there are there is a strong scientific
argument to be made that you are not
unconscious during anesthesia you're
just
incoherent so you you cannot focus on
any particular experience
no no no it means that you do not suffer
there is too much incoherence in brain
signals to form
the coherent experience of a profound
pain
it can't happen because the signal is
dispersed to your conscious self but
what if there are other parts of you
that are feeling it that can remember
much like when you have childhood trauma
and then you dissociate
there is a part of you that's filling
everything that can possibly be felt has
ever been felt and will ever be felt
right if it's almost unconsciousness
there is a part of you correct correct
but that's and that's going to
be about death about that where was i
going to death yeah so
the best model we have is psychedelics
actually not not
anesthesia because psychedelics under
neuroimaging
they have been proven every psychedelic
studied so far since 2012 until now
has have this consistent behavior brain
activity significantly reduces
especially
in the default mode network the part of
your brain that has to do with your
individual sense of self
the part of your brain the process in
your brain that says
i am curt or i am
bernardo the that part of brain
activities is
this is smashed your brain goes to sleep
in that regard
and and and i know from experience that
um
the experience that is correlated with
that which is called ego dissolution
is an incredibly difficult
experience to undergo it's when you're
constantly dying and you're never dead
it's that feeling that of losing
everything that you
are or what have you experienced yeah i
have experienced uh ego dissolution
under high dose psychedelics more than
once
does it get easier
in a certain way yes in a certain way no
the feelings are never less powerful so
in that sense it does not
get easier the feelings are just as
intense i've experienced something
akin to eco death where it's like i'm in
a oneness
i'm in a void but it wasn't black it was
white but i felt like
almost like the tentacles of an octopus
and then you go back to the head
and i couldn't explain it any other way
and everything made sense
you get this profound realization that
oh the laws of physics are the way
because of so-and-so but then you forget
so and so
and then even if you do remember it days
later you're like that doesn't make
sense
discard it the the tentacles are the
dissociative pathways and you are
undergoing a reduction in dissociation
and your mind presents itself to you in
a pictorial manner
and then you're going back from the
tentacles to the head to the godhead
from the dissociated tentacles it makes
all sense of the world
but look nobody has ever physically died
from psychedelic ingestion it's not
physically possible people die of the
stupidity they do
while under the influence but your ego
does die
you as a body don't but your ego your
sense of an individual agency of being
an individual agent
that senses smashed to smithereens
and it feels as death because it smashes
that
which you think you are and it feels
horrible
so doing it repeatedly it feels as
horrible but there is one silver lining
and that is
you know what's happening and there's a
little voice in the back of your head
saying
just hang on tight this will pass and
there is bliss
on the other side and there is because
when your sense of individual self
dissolves
you are the universe and that's such a
it's the greatest joy one can imagine
it's a profound sense of identification
with the true
reality and everything else until that
point was an illusion
and it's a reality of total acceptance
total integration
because you are that which needs to
accept so it completes an
unconditional acceptance but before that
heaven
there is the hell of ego dissociation
parting with that uh
what did i say ego dissociation meant
ego dissolution
which corresponds to a reduction in
dissociation because the ego
is the dissociative process so when the
ego dissolves it's the dissociation that
is dissolving
a reuniting a reintegration which is
blissful
except that in that in-between stage it
feels like you are being
annihilated your soul is being
annihilated
and and it's the worst experience that i
think
that i have ever had no worse than that
is the re-entries when you are in the
bliss and then you come back to the ego
that's worse
um but ego the solution is terrible and
uh
and my own theory informed me that
physical death real death permanent
death when you die and you're dead
um that's the ultimate ego dissolution
so i know bliss is coming and i will
know blizzard coming and i'm thankful to
psychedelics for that
for not telling me this only
conceptually but
showing me what it is so being convinced
to the bone
that ultimately bliss is coming but i
shiver
by thinking of what ultimate ego
dissolution might feel like
and i dread it and i fear it
profoundly and i didn't fear it when i
was a sort of
unthinking materialist by default
because
there's literally nothing to fear when
you're you're dead
there is nobody there to feel bad it
takes such strength to admit that
because most people are the opposite
where they'll say
i was fearful of death when i was a
materialist then i died with ego
dissolution
that's right dissolution and then i came
back and i realized okay well death is
just another state
that is not much different than this and
it's blissful and so on
well you know if what you told me about
sam harry is saying that you can
trust what he says because it goes
against what he wishes
if that's true i mean that's nonsensical
even if it's true that he
that he thinks that i mean it's the
ultimate logical fallacy
uh uh this is not a logical argument for
the validity of your position to say
well i fear it
so yes i could apply that to myself and
you're you're doing me the favor of
doing that you're being very kind to me
but to be a very honest kurt i don't
think this means anything it has no
logical force whether i like the
conclusion or not
has no bearing on the force of my
argument for that conclusion
people should look at my argument does
my argument hold water
so if some harris thinks i should trust
what he says because it goes against
what
against what he wishes i would say
[ __ ] i don't give a
damn what you wish or don't wish tell me
your argument i would judge your
argument
not how you feel about it no i agree i
agree so the fact that i feel bad
about the idealist sense of death that
consciousness persists and we want to go
you get the solution i do fear that and
i'm saying that to you not because i'm
trying to promote myself on the other
precisely the contrary but i don't think
you or anybody should construe this
as something that helps the force of my
argument it shouldn't
my argument hopefully is objective how i
feel about its implications
should be relevant it is relevant to me
when people go in states and they say
that what i experienced was real it was
more real than this
you talked about this a few times then
we dismissed that reality
should we be now there are good reasons
to dismiss it because
i imagine well this is just a
speculation on my part though it's
though there's some basis to it i think
professor
john vervicky said that the sense of
realness can be induced
there's a cortical loop inside your
brain and the faster it goes there's a
certain
cortical loop i don't recall which one
the faster it is the more you feel like
that's real whatever it is
so then you could say well psychedelic
spin that wheel quicker so you feel as
if it's real but it's not necessarily
yeah yeah yeah
so then how do we okay yeah my
relationship with psychedelic noses
is probably the reverse of what most
psychonauts would
report i'm not really a psychonaut i did
that as a sort of a
part of a research effort it's not
something that i was exultant about
doing
it's you know if i'm talking if i'm
going to talk about consciousness i
better know what i'm talking about
so i felt obliged to do that and it has
been contributed a lot
to my development as a person so i'm
thankful to psychedelics for that even
though i think it's not for everyone
and should be done with extreme care and
not done when it's not legal
um my sense of psychedelic knows this is
the following there is
no doubt that when you are
deep within a trip when you pass those
initial stages
which are hallucinatory in nature but
when you pass through that when you
break through
really to the other side there is no
doubting
that that feeling that this is
ultra real this is a lot more real than
where i was coming from i was completely
deluded i was in some kind of trance
and now i see what's really real so that
experience
exists there's no doubt about that can
you explain it away
no doubt about that either whether the
explanations are
true or not i reserve judgment but can
you in principle explain that sense of
reality away
in the way you suggested like something
spinning some mental process spinning
faster in your brain
possibly is that what is relevant about
this
i would say no it's completely
irrelevant let me tell you
what is relevant about that sense of
realness
it's stronger than the sense of realness
you have now
so if you can explain that away on the
same basis
you explain you can explain this away
right now so the message of the
psychedelic experience from me
is not that that is real and this is an
illusion
the message is that this is an illusion
do you see what i mean if you think
flip flip it around turn it the other
way around the message is not that's
real
the message is this is not real in the
way we
think it is real this too
is a mental configuration it's something
that
mind is doing so if mind can do
something
that makes you have that sense of ultra
reality in a psychedelic state
and you explain that away by saying it's
just mind
please be consistent with yourself and
do the same here
if your sense of reality now is less
real than that
please tell yourself inform yourself
this too
is a trick of mine there that is the
important thing